dropsy seconds to apply three you wanted
new bark
you could have just asked me
the device that controls every military
satellite in the world is falling into
the hands of four very dangerous guys we
need someone who can move like them
fight like them it's time to be patriot
there are no more Patriots just rebel
and tyrants so which are you
I'm xxx I'll introduce you to your
ground team all right it comes Red Bulls
poster child I'm not gonna have clowns
watch my back who would you trust a good
the extreme Pratley completely insane Oh
what you want what you need now that's
the team I can work with here you go
refreshing you actually know what you're
doing down there
yeah that's what she says Wow he's Casey
Jones are the real kind of trouble you
have no idea what you're up against
whatever it is you're looking for
gonna come up short this is me you're
not making me breakfast in the water
we're willing to die to keep the world
safe how about you I live for this I
guess we're on the same team now you
ready to have some fun
we simplify flea kick some ass get the
girl and try to look dope why are you
doing
Danah feels good to be back fast we kick
some ass and try to look dope why are
you doing
you